[Music]
this is a very important story
the important story
in the midst of covet 19 it's an
historic opportunity to look at the
facts of the world as it is
and then to focus on the solutions to
some of our greatest problems
in the 75 years since the united nations
was founded
the human race has never had to face a
set of challenges like we do
right now but together we can overcome
them
it's a myth that each and every one of
us doesn't have the ability to change
the world
dramatically and quickly there have been
enormous shifts in power
and behavior to the benefit of all
humanity and it can happen again
nelson mandela said it always seems
impossible
until it's done these
are some of the things that must be done
in grace
how sweet
the sound
that's
[Music]
like me
i once
was lost
but now i'm
[Music]
i see
september 2020 the world is still in the
grip of a global pandemic
there have been more than 27 million
confirmed cases
and more than 900 000 people have died
billions of people have been in lockdown
for months
lives and livelihoods have been
threatened
and lost but as some lockdowns are
easing
people are emerging into a different
uncertain world
with a new appetite for change
today we feel the weight of history on
our shoulders
the covey 19 pandemic this channel of
fred drive
do all this a microscopic virus
has put us on our knees and that
fragility should make us
humble covert 19 has been likened to an
x-ray
exposing fractures in the skeleton of
the societies we have built
a world with great inequality which must
be righted
[Music]
and a world which must win the battle
against climate catastrophe
the whole planet is at stake so this is
a moment to recognize
that the way we have been moving leads
nowhere and that we need to change
course
the lockdowns also showed that our
environment itself
can change in the punjab for the first
time in generations
the himalayas are visible once again
lions have reclaimed the roads in kruger
national park
in venice the canals run clear once more
and across italy dolphins have returned
if you look at the response of people to
cover 19
people dramatically change their lives
but people have shown an enormous
capacity to adapt to new circumstances
and enormous capacity
to change the way they live the way they
work
the way they organize themselves
[Music]
so change is possible the problem is
political will
it is so decided
[Applause]
on the 25th of september 2015
all united nations member states signed
up to the sustainable development goals
a set of solutions for the biggest
problems the world faces
we're going to look at the four key
areas where we must
take urgent action starting with climate
and our planet
next door's on fire oh my god
okay i'm scared you're at risk
leaving now is the safest option so
leave now towards the beach and shelter
in place
oh my god my name is house okay
come on clay we need to go
oh my god
this is a real nightmare i can't believe
this is real
i can't see anything this is literally
not real
this is not real oh my freaking god
[Music]
all i want is my family
pictures and stories continue to file
out from australia about the devastating
fires
this one a satellite image from nasa
[Music]
arriving fastest
the damage to pastures and crops could
create
severe consequences for the region where
nearly 12 million people are
it could be the worst the area has seen
in 20 years
this is double whammy you know we're
dealing with a cyclone and with exposure
to covers well the fire is raging in
northern california
have now become some of the largest in
state history more than 12
000 firefighters are currently battling
the places that have the san francisco
bay area
smothered by some of the worst air
quality on the planet
valley reaches an all-time high of a
hundred is difficult
[Music]
[Applause]
i think this is the most important issue
that we need to be talking about
climate change is here now and it is
killing people
right now the people who are looking at
it right in the face
the next 8 to 10 years is going to
determine the quality of life for the
next
100 to 200 years
we all watched with amazement when
exactly one year ago
young people from all over the world
took to the streets to express their
feeling that we're not doing enough
about climate change
that we're not treating it like the
emergency it is
it's a year later now have we done
enough no
we have not and climate change is only
part of this story
our rain forests are disappearing at an
extraordinary rate
one football field of rainforest is
destroyed every six seconds
one million plant and animal species are
on the brink of extinction
by 2050 there will be more plastic in
the oceans
than fish and so climate change and our
treatment of the natural world
are colliding and exacerbating each
other to create a perfect storm
this cannot go on you know it i know it
and we know what we need to do
we need to reduce global emissions by 50
by 2030.
to do this we need a rapid but just
transition to renewable energy
that means an end to the building of new
coal power stations and an
end to subsidizing of fossil fuels
government should also shift the tax
burden from payrolls to carbon
taxing carbon rather than people will
increase output
and employment while reducing emissions
and we need to stop deforestation in its
tracks
planting trees instead of chopping them
down
we need to think about what we eat and
how we produce food
embracing healthy nutritious diets
sustainable farming methods and reducing
food waste
[Music]
the climate crisis is an opportunity
renewable energy is cheaper than fossil
fuels
thousands of businesses are working to
go carbon neutral and the opportunity to
generate
clean safe and decent jobs is enormous
the passion for protests can turn into a
passion for changing all of our behavior
to create a better safer just
sustainable world
the big question we have to ask
ourselves now is this as a species
are we going to be able to work together
urgently to solve this
the clock is ticking
[Music]
poverty and inequality are universal
they undermine every society everywhere
but poverty is not natural
it is man-made so poverty is not
inevitable it's an area where the world
has made huge progress in the past
few decades
[Music]
just 30 years ago there were 1.9 billion
people living in extreme poverty
but that number has been transformed
in 2015 it fell to 734 million people
that's over a billion people lifted out
of poverty
[Music]
billion people out of poverty is amazing
it was across the world we lifted people
out of poverty
across the world more kids got into
education as across the world
maternal mortality was reduced across
the world today
not many people will be left without
access
to a mobile phone and what that has done
to empower them to to access
education to a livelihood is huge
but still almost 10 of the human race is
living
unbelievably harsh lives
this is largely determined by their
circumstances at birth
and these high levels of inequality work
against
better opportunities for all
opportunities
that could change the world
[Music]
i want to tell you a story about
1999.
i used to teach people how to write
computer programs
and i had a very you know plush office
and everything
and just outside of these offices there
was this large sprawling
urban slump full of children
so one day i tried an experiment i made
an opening
in the boundary wall that separated my
offices from the slum
and then i fixed a computer so that from
the other side of the wall
you could see the computer and a touch
pad
on the first day we saw this
eight-year-old
boy teaching a six-year-old girl
how to surf
[Music]
how on earth did he figure that out
how did he know what the computer was
doing
three months after i had first put their
computer in the wall
the children said they wanted a faster
processor and a better mouse
i asked them how on earth do you know
these words
where did you learn this from and they
said well you
you've left a machine here that speaks
only in english
so we had no option but to learn the
language
easy isn't it
i repeated the hole in the wall
experiment
for five years across the length and
breadth of india
in a village 300 miles away from delhi
one girl is explaining to the other girl
what a neuron is
they're just 12 years old
wow we have hope
we have an enormous potential
of what children can achieve together
if we let them
[Music]
there is potential everywhere we just
have to unlock it
a huge amount depends on where public
money is spent
more of it must urgently go into health
into giving everyone a safety net
there is a revolution that is happening
in education
connecting every school every person to
the internet
this can be done
the recovery from covert must lead to an
economy that works for everyone
let's start with tax we have widespread
tax concessions tax avoidance and tax
evasion
which means that there's so much less
money for all the crucial things
many developing countries are weighed
down by historical debts
spending more money on debt repayments
than they are spending on health care
and then there's the importance of
global investment
in peace
the peace dividend for the world is
immeasurable
and we must break the vicious cycle of
corruption
and increase the power of the people to
keep check
on the people in power
a free independent media and responsible
social media platforms
that encourage healthy debate equality
unleashes the potential of everyone to
improve their own lives
and contribute to the lives of everyone
[Music]
else
whatever it is coronavirus has made the
mighty kneel
and brought the world to a halt like
nothing else could
our minds are still racing back and
forth longing for a return to
normality trying to stitch our future to
our past
and refusing to acknowledge the rupture
but the rupture exists
and in the midst of this terrible
despair it offers us a chance to
rethink the doomsday machine we have
built for ourselves
nothing could be worse than a return to
normality
[Music]
historically pandemics have forced
humans to break with the past
and imagine the world anew this one is
no different
it's a portal a gateway between one
world and the next
we can choose to walk through it
dragging the carcasses of our prejudice
and hatred our avarice our data banks
and dead ideas
we can walk through it lightly with
little luggage
ready to imagine another world and ready
to fight for it
after the genocide and destruction of
the second world war
the united nations was founded
enshrined in its charter was the fact
that all people are equal
and entitled to the same respect justice
and human rights
this remains a simple truth and yet
across the globe
the struggle is still being fought there
is a certain
outrage for injustice right now i think
that that is happening in every sphere
i think we're at a moment where covet
perhaps has helped us realize that there
is an intergenerational transition
and that young people now waking up to
the calls that we've had
from my generation which have said look
this is the
opportunity you've got to make things
change i mean they are rising up and
that we are bringing young people to the
table now
not as a token but to help us shape
and to take that batten to take up the
gauntlet and to move forward
people fighting for justice but fighting
for
your justice not just mine and to see
that without your justice
mine won't be fulfilled either
[Music]
the world knows him as george
but i called him perry
yesterday we laid him to rest
it was the hardest thing i ever had to
do
i'm the big brother now so it's my job
to come for my brothers
and my sisters perry's kids
and everyone who loved him and that's a
lot of people
i couldn't take care of george that day
he was killed
but i can make sure that his death
would not be in vain
to make sure that he is more than
another face on a t-shirt
more than another name on the list that
won't stop growing
george called for help and he was
ignored
please listen to the cow ringing out the
streets across the world
people of all backgrounds genders and
races
have come together to demand change
[Music]
the people marching in the streets are
telling you enough is enough
[Applause]
to the leaders the people elected you to
speak for them
to make positive change you have the
opportunity to make your names mean
something too
if his death end up changing the world
for the better and i think it will
[Music]
then he died as he lived
[Music]
it is on you to make sure his death is
not in vain
perry look up at what you did
big brother you changed the world
i hope you can rest in peace with power
[Music]
i remember when i couldn't level up i
was trying but i got the level up it was
wrong
stop feeling like i had enough then i
contemplated giving up
if you're feeling like you can't pull
when you start feeling like you can't
level up that's when you have to shut
the devil up
i remember when i cut the level up no my
money couldn't level up
doing what i must i'm like there's
always another level up
that's why you always find me looking up
but sometimes
not my life you know my forever love my
hair about my fights in the club
every day may try never love someone
striking i'm hard may go
out until i get to
[Music]
[Music]
you have to fight
[Music]
thank you
inequality for women is one of the
world's great injustices
and it is an injustice that must be and
will be
swept away 75 percent of
parliamentarians are men
73 percent of managerial decision makers
are men 67 percent of climate
negotiators
are men and 87
of the people at the peace table are men
even though we know that when peace
settlements include women
the negotiations and outcomes are more
durable
globally almost one in five women has
experienced violence in the past
12 months at the hands of a man they
know
women and girls do three times as much
unpaid care and domestic work as men
the global gender pay gap is stuck at 16
every year 12 million girls are married
before 18.
all of this has to change
it's time to stop trying to change women
and start changing the systems
that prevent them from achieving their
potential
[Music]
and this is the battle that women in
this century will not
lose they are too strong
and their voices will not be silenced
[Music]
i was named after a girl
an afghani folk hero was killed in a
battle
just after i was born my father got our
family tree
it went back 300 years but not a single
girl or woman's name
appeared on it he decided to make me the
first
he wrote malala that's me
when her father's school was closed down
by the taliban
malala yousafzai began to campaign for
the right of young girls across the
country to go to school
i have rights i have the right of
education i have the right to play
i have the right to sing i have the
right to talk i have the right to go to
market
i have the right to speak up
they shot her in the head she is still
in critical condition
[Music]
she was airlifted to a military hospital
in peshawar
where she had surgery as surgeons
battled to save her life
vigils took place throughout the
[Music]
in this world photo released today
malala's eyes are open
and cheap they've got some really good
news to report tonight malala yusuf
walked out of a london hospital today
today it is an honor for me
to be speaking again after a long time
they thought that the bullet would
silence us
but they failed
[Music]
my message right now is to young people
we are living in a world where things
are not the way we want
we are getting a system we're getting a
world which is
which is unequal which is sexist which
is racist we have systems that are
discriminating against people
uh our climate or environment is at risk
and there's so much that needs to be
done but i hope that young people
they stand up they raise their voices uh
they start
their activism right now let your age
not stop you oftentimes we are told that
you know you have to be 40 and 50 to
change the world i do not believe in
that
i think you can be a change maker right
now if you are 11 if you are 16 if you
are
you know 30 40 change is possible
anytime and i want you to believe in
yourself
and make this world a fairer more equal
and a better place for each and every
one
and once again there are positive
solutions that can turn things around
fast
[Music]
we need more women in positions of power
at every level of government the time
has come
for quotas that make sure women are
equally represented
in every country it's time to make our
laws
equal so that every woman is entitled to
a job
and a national identification card and
to own property
women must be able to live free from
violence
and have the right to make decisions
over their bodies and lives
especially in choosing if and when they
marry
we must guarantee full access to sexual
and reproductive health services and
rights
we must provide the money to close the
gap in girls education
and there are important changes needed
to achieve economic empowerment for
women
from equal access to finance to ending
the gender pay gap
to equal access to the digital world
from mobile bank accounts
to digital payment systems and digital
education
it just doesn't make sense women are
half of the population
but society does not treat them as
equals
this is a legacy that needs to change
here
and now by changing our behaviors but
also by changing laws and common
practices across the world
we must all make that happen now
everyone can do their part to make it
happen
we can create and enjoy green jobs live
healthier lives with cleaner air
and better diets and in more equal
societies all of us
men and women can enjoy safer and more
productive lives
there is power in every decision we make
we can shape society
and the future of our planet and people
in every choice we make
my final message is let's be humble
let's recognize our fragilities and
let's understand
that only in unity and solidarity we
will be able to address them
it's true in each one of our countries
it's true at global level
and let's take profit of the 75th
anniversary of the united nations
to think together how better we can
organize
the international community to address
climate change
inequality pandemics like the kovite 19
and so many other aspects that can only
be solved
if we join together and if we are able
to have
one common strategy one common project
and
one common determination in favor of
peace
of development and human rights in the
[Music]
world
[Music]
[Music]
regret it's something to
remember so they won't forget
i was here
[Music]
i was here
that i wanted and it was more than i
thought it would
[Music]
did my best brought someone from
[Music]
[Applause]
happiness
[Music]
i was here
[Applause]
here
[Applause]
you